son premier coup de sang de la saison
pour le directeur sportif des templiers
d'elancourt frederick henderson ses
joueurs n'ont pas réussi remporté ce
samedi 20 janvier leur premier match de
la saison de 2e division contre les
vikings de villeneuve d'ascq score final
8 partout fait beaucoup trop d'erreurs
au final des erreurs d'exécution des
erreurs qu'on n'a pas qu'on n'a pas
commise sur les matches de préparation
et qu'on retrouve ici alors que c'était
les mêmes types de défense qu'on avait à
affronter
on s'attendait pas à ce résultat la fera
qu'on s'attendait à mener très
rapidement dans la gamme principale
raison invoquée pour expliquer ces
erreurs techniques et conditions
climatiques difficiles la pluie tombée
pendant toute la rencontre sur le
complexe sportif
on a dû changer un peu nos quand sur les
coups de pied de dégagement par exemple
on a dû jusqu'à ligne et échanger
stratégie à cause du vent et puis de la
pluie on a vu que les coups de pied
d'engagement il portait beaucoup moins
loin que d'habitude
ce qui fait que les return n'allait pas
forcément chercher les ballons très vite
j'aimerais qu'on s'est mis en danger de
trois fois sur des erreurs bêtes
annoncé comme l'un des favoris à la
montée avant la rencontre et l'encours
se retrouve dans le milieu de classement
de la poule 2 avec ce match nul
une situation qui n'inquiète pas le
staff le potentiel est toujours là on
est toujours mieux que l'année dernière
par contre le potentiel si on n'arrive
pas à concrétiser sur le terrain ça se
transforme en victoire et on attendra
par nos objectifs donc bien sûr je suis
optimiste vis-à-vis de ce qu'ils sont
capables de produire la vérité du
terrain c'est celle du match et le
tableau de score il en a rien à faire
des escales s'entraîner six disques en
moi si on performe pas les scores sont
pas là on gagne pas la séance de
rattrapage est programmée ce dimanche 28
janvier sur le terrain des diables
rouges de villepinte une équipe qui
s'est inclinée lors de son premier match
de la saison